foreign
what's up Catherine
hi Dr Delaney I deeply appreciate you
speaking with me today I appreciate you
calling in how can I help
so my question is I have a 30 year old
son almost 31 who has struggled with
addiction mental illness for the past
nine ten years
and
I've just become so frustrated that I
I'm wondering is it ever okay to just
say hey don't contact me
until you've been sober for a year or
some amount of time
yes
and
my mom knows that's okay but how do I
tell the rest of me my heart and my
emotions and I mean because it's been a
roller coaster for you know years is is
what's he running from
[Music]
okay
it was back in 2007
um
my daughter and I handled it you know
we talked to each other but he would
just be completely shut down if you
cried about it it was just like you
could see him trying to run out of the
room and at the time you you know I went
to therapy and they recommend they did
not recommend me forcing him
because he said you know that's not
going to help if he's unwilling
and now I feel like he's unwilling to
stick with anything in his life you know
I mean
he's just he's been in and out of
psychiatric hospitals treatment centers
homeless
and it's heartbreaking and I you know I
know
from my own counseling and from trying
to be healthy myself that I can't
control what he's doing but I just don't
know how to sit with it and accept it
maybe that's the better thing
um
and I feel like the resources in our
country are pretty
it's a super hard when he gets in a
hospital and still
things happen and he doesn't get help
it's just you know it's
it's a struggle because there's just not
much to do to help somebody no matter
how mentally ill he seems yeah and it
sounds like he's dealing less with
mental health issues and more psychosis
he has I mean he has struggled with both
but it's very hard for me to tell you if
it's more a drug thing or a mental
health thing I truly believe he has
mental health issues
but because he continuously turns to
drugs it's it's hard to know yeah when
those tend to braid together over time
to where it's so hard to extrapolate you
really have to have a period of intense
true sobriety to pull that apart
sometimes that's just so hard to get to
um and I mean we've turned on having him
at home with us trying to make sure he
sees a psychiatrist but ultimately
some of his psychosis
is kind of terrifying you know he's told
me before I I want to kill the person
who's taken over my mom and he's talking
to me and my my daughter is a police
officer and she sends me things you know
saying please don't let him be at home
people get killed that way you know and
it just my mind again I come back to my
mind knows it's not safe but my heart
is just having a real hard time with it
and I would tell you that you're right
on both counts
you have a right to be safe
you have a right to your boundaries
you have a right to not be threatened
you have a right to have your home not
stolen like robbed right
you have a right to not have drugs in
your home or to have vomit and urine all
over the place you have a right to that
and
God it's heartbreaking
to have my son yeah both of those things
are true and what you're trying to do is
have one without the other and you can't
and so where I would start if I I'm
trying to just think think ahead here
um
number one I can't I can't even wrap my
head around it
um
because I know like you I'd go to the
ends of the Earth for my kids
right the end of time like I have but it
hasn't changed anything exactly that's
just it so the first thing you've got to
do
is write Catherine a letter
okay
and the first line of that letter is
Catherine it's not your fault
because you're still harboring some
guilt that somehow if you had done
something a little different or done of
things this way or that way or had to
listen to this one piece of advice for
this one all of this would be different
yes that's true and that kind of
thinking I get it it's not helpful
because here's where we are right now
and when we live into that guilt and in
your case I
should have done something different
turns into uh um I did something dumb or
I wish I'd done something different
turns into I'm a bad mom
this is my fault
if he dies that one's on me
yes and that's the difference between
guilt and shame
okay I can sit down with you and tell
you things I should have said
differently to my son Hank my daughter
Josephine there's a few things that will
haunt me till I die
I wish I'd said this differently or not
done this one
and the more I dwell on that the more I
intentionally disconnect myself from
myself and from them in in the present
it does no good right it's not helpful
I learned my lesson and I think I'm a
good dad
and I'm gonna believe that you're a good
mom
yeah and so first letter is to Catherine
it's not your fault here's the things
that happened
I don't hold anybody accountable for the
decisions they make after their husband
up and just dies
yeah
it's trauma on top of trauma and
suddenly you're a single mom in Kentucky
in the middle of an economic meltdown I
mean you know what I'm saying
right you've got to give that Catherine
some Grace
the second letter goes to your son
you're never going to give it to him
but it's going to be to that 15 year old
little boy who lost his dad
yeah
and you're going to tell them the things
that you've been swirling around in your
head for the last 10 15 years that you
didn't say that you still haunt yourself
with
um you're going to say those things
okay okay and then here's the third
letter
it might be one you consider sending
this is one that will be here are my
boundaries moving forward
it will not be okay to come to my house
if you've been using period you're not
welcome here I'll call the police
you're not welcome which I have done yes
yeah
um
your access to my money is and anyone in
our family's money is zero we will not
give you any more money this is a hard
conversation and we're having it right
now
if he's homeless and I don't know I mean
I don't I really couldn't send that
letter because I don't know where he is
right that's that's keep it to yourself
but okay you don't have to send it what
I'm saying is it's important to get
those boundaries out of your head and
onto paper it's like making a budget
like when I when I'm I bought a guitar
yesterday and
I'm not gonna lie Catherine it's an
incredible guitar but I started doing
some I started doing the math in my head
the math in my head is very different
than my budget in reality you know what
I mean
like I think I spent this last week
about a scope for a new rifle the other
day so I got this yeah I think we're
yeah I think we're good Captain we are
not good not good at all right so the
more those boundaries swirl around on
your head the more likely you are to
make an impulse purchase
the more likely you are to be exhausted
on a Friday night to be two beers and a
whole pizza into a Friday evening and he
shows up and you're like just go to the
back room and go to bed
yeah and now we're back into square one
again all your boundaries mean nothing
he knows that
um now you gotta repaint the bathroom
and you've got to fix the sheets and you
gotta you know what I'm saying all that
so have your boundaries written down so
that you are very clear you might get
somebody to do it with you
maybe your daughter maybe somebody
whoever's somebody you trust my husband
now is very good at helping with that
although he's given it a try to help him
as well he's good with the boundaries
he's he's a good support for me because
he sees that we need the boundaries
there you go but and that helps me
here's something important Catherine he
can't write the boundaries he's got to
just support you while you do it yes and
and that's true and I understand that
you'll get mad at him at 2am
if you haven't been the one that set
these boundaries right correct yes
that's 100 right so you do the hard work
of writing them down and then you'll
have to build an ecosystem where
Catherine you have to decide you're
worth being well
you have to decide you're worth a great
marriage
you're worth laughing going to play
bingo I don't know what you do in
Lexington Kentucky go ride horses I
don't know what y'all do
um but that you have to not cash out of
your life because your son isn't doing
well and is has
uh bias choices and just by virtue of
his illness
um has become unsafe to be around
do this he can get the help he needs if
he chose to correct I've had some people
in recovery tell me
that he can it's just he's not
doing the steps to get there because I
always want to feel his mental illness
is so bad that he can't do any
differently than what he's doing and
maybe I'm making an excuse no I I think
it's both and
um I stopped a long time ago
pointing my fingers at people who are
struggling with addiction
and struggling mental health
um I used to say why I can't believe
someone would do meth and not and walk
away from their kids that person sucks
now I think to myself
God Almighty what what happened to that
person what's what has gotten into their
soul that the only way they can get
through days with methamphetamine
yeah and it's a much more empathetic
approach but it doesn't change my
boundaries you cannot come inside my
home if you're high
you cannot come in my house if you are
stoned my empathy is different I'm not
judging you and I'm not angry with you
but you have to meet me halfway and
halfway is safety and sobriety
halfway is right and it might be a part
of your boundaries are you and your
husband go ahead and have a number if he
came to you and said I've been sober for
six months I've been work I've been
mowing lawns a couple days a week I'm
ready to go to rehab
y'all might have a number like we'll put
in 10 000 on that or we'll put in five
grand on that or whatever you may have
that go ahead and set that aside in your
boundaries
um
and give him something to lean into
but he is choosing to not be in
relationship with you not the other way
around
that is true okay you are not choosing
to kick your son out of your house
because he can't get his crap together
that's not what we're doing
oh sure he is opting
out of relationship with you for
whatever reason and that is the most
heartbreaking thing a parent can
experience as their kids opting out for
whatever reason addiction mental health
all that yes there are resources and yes
I dare say there are people that could
help him if if he made the decision to
go I also would say there are moments
when the Mental Health Plus
thank you
the wrong meth fentanyl combination I do
believe there's some moments when you
melt some circuitry and it's just I
don't know you get it back
yeah
super intelligent growing up and I can
tell that it's definitely changed and he
might have undiagnosed schizophrenia and
drugs helps him get through it it helps
clarify things a little bit
I do think that's one of the diagnosis
he's been given in the past if he's got
schizophrenia you don't stay somewhere
long enough right to ever know that for
sure sure
um if he does have schizophrenia and and
he could actually go get stabilized and
get the right medication and get on a
routine for 30 60 90 120 days you'd see
a different human being this is hard to
get there
it's hard to get someone else to do that
that's right we've we've tried to
regulate meds and yeah it's all that
it's like my last caller right it's it's
at some point somebody's got to decide
I don't know how this works and I know
that I'm I'm having hallucinations and
I'm hearing voices but I want to
have a different life
man that's hard that's hard that's hard
that's hard that's hard
especially oh this makes sense to me and
not just you know I
I know the boundaries thing is important
and safety yeah I mean so it's a safety
issue I want you to get a journal and
every time you feel super heartbroken
you feel that Mom guilt you feel that
wave of I failed him write that down
write those feelings down and challenge
them is that true
have you been a terrible Mom did you
really fail him
I bet the answer is no
is your son sick absolutely is it
heartbreaking yes does he have
permission to threaten to kill you no
is it devastating to know your kid is
homeless
especially when there's medications out
there that could probably help him that
there's treatment plans and people that
would help him oh my gosh I can't I
can't wrap my head around how
devastating that would be
and yet I have to know the limits of my
own power and I can't drag somebody
kicking and screaming
to their own Wellness
[ __ ]
it's hard it's hard it's hard
I'm sorry it's just as just parent to
parent I'm sorry
you're a good mom Catherine